[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 93
is it that's right that's right three
we are slightly discombobulated having
just returned from a fantastic if brief
excursion to the san juan islands yeah
it was terrific for those of you who
don't
uh know the san juans uh the most
northwest uh territory of the lower 48
in the united states they it's an
archipelago
um that is that is divided in half by a
political line right the um the gulf
islands of canada are part of the same
archipelago and you know really so is
vancouver island but they are
extraordinary really extraordinary
yes they really are an amazing amazing
place and with an amazing history and we
will be talking more about them next
week
it was a little bit difficult to get
some of the photographs from uh our trip
wrestled into shape because we arrived
so late last night so next week we'll
talk more about the san juans and all we
learned and thought we did indeed and
more and more
more immediately a little
discombobulated because you just brought
me water we just got back
we had left our cats in the capable care
of a young woman and uh they missed us
and um one of them is now sitting here
drinking with his paw from my water and
spraying it all over my computer yes
rendering the amount of water that you
have at your disposal suddenly
zero it's desertification right here on
the podcast yeah happening in real time
so we are going to continue our
march through uh through the chapters of
our forthcoming book today we're going
to be talking
about school which is uh which is the
topic of chapter 10 of a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century which will be out in less than a
month at this point
but first if you're watching on youtube
consider trying it out on odyssey that's
where the chat is if you're watching
live um
we have disabled the chat on youtube uh
only because it's very difficult for the
moderators to keep track of two chats at
a time
but the chat is just as good on odyssey
um you can submit questions for the q a
that will happen after this uh this main
live stream on darkhorsesubmissions.com
and there's a there's frequently asked
questions there for for any questions
that you have you can also email
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com with um not
with your questions for us but any
logistical questions
consider joining one or both of our
patreons right now the open question
period is uh is open for
yeah we haven't been here for a while no
no uh for the private q a on my patreon
that happens with both of us on the last
sunday of the month uh so uh you can you
can go there right now we're doing a
covet free q a this month at the request
of some of the patrons last month so
uh i've taken a look at the questions
that have already come in and there's uh
there's a great diversity of questions
um and nothing having to do with coping
covid free we will still be maintaining
every precaution against the disease but
uh the question the content of the
questions will be covered free yeah the
q a being virtual makes it rather easy
it simplifies things greatly it does it
does um
you can find shirts and other other
stuff at
darkhorsestore.darkhorsepodcast.org and
consider joining me
at naturalselections.substack.com
my post this week was about herons and
watson
which are
forget fermenting
amazonian birds
and it's very very rare
for flyers to be grazers because leaves
are such of such low caloric
quality
and flying takes so much energy um and
not only are leaves of such low quality
but it takes a lot of them it takes a
lot of like space in your gut to achieve
fermentation
and so as it turns out we've seen watson
in the wild and the amazon and they fly
really
badly they're amazing birds they're
they're amazing birds they s they they
smell bad and they fly badly and it
turns out it's not because they're just
kind of lazy or slothful or bad at
flying because they don't put the energy
in um they actually there's not much um
room for the flight muscles to attach
because their foreguts are taking up
like all this space and so they just
they don't have the lift that other
birds of similar size would have it's
like a tropical
tree chicken with a vegetarian diet
yeah except they're not
chickens right it's not even clear what
they are like i went i dove down to that
little phylogenetic rabbit hole like who
are they related to it's not clear it's
still an open question turrico's maybe
doves maybe dubs is one possibility
doves yeah
i could almost see that yeah but the
wild makeup around the eyes is yeah just
crazy on these birds yeah and the
as you say right yeah the crest for the
for the audience
[Laughter]
exactly okay so um before we get into
talking about uh about school today we
have two ads two ads for you two
sponsors of the show today mud water and
public goods
[Music]
all right mud water is a coffee
alternative with four adaptogenic
mushrooms and ayurvedic herbs with
one-seventh the caffeine is a cup of
coffee you get energy without the
anxiety jitters or crash of coffee
each ingredient was added for a purpose
by the makers of mud water cacao and
chai from mood and micro dose of
caffeine lion's mane for alertness
cordyceps to help support physical
performance chaga and reishi to support
your immune system turmeric for soreness
and cinnamon for antioxidants
and i will say this as i said the first
time that we ran an ad from mud water i
enjoy my coffee um but i don't need it
and that's intentional i've spent time
places where coffee was was not or might
not be available and so i intentionally
reduced my dose to zero every now and
again just to make sure i don't need it
won't get headaches without it etc um so
i wasn't sure that i wanted or needed a
coffee alternative but i've been
drinking it off and on for several uh
weeks now and i really like it in fact i
didn't have any when we were away in the
san juans um but i had some this morning
and i really enjoy it the chocolate i'm
sucker for chocolate and the masala chai
blend which includes a number of spices
that anyone who enjoys masala which i
will be familiar with cinnamon turmeric
ginger cardamom black pepper nutmeg
cloves is really good
um
it's got all the things you would expect
of a company like mud water it's 100
usda organic non-gmo gluten-free vegan
kosher certified furthermore they donate
a percentage of their revenue to maps
the multidisciplinary association for
psychedelic studies now this is not a
psychedelic drink but that is uh
whom they donate some of their revenue
to and they work with an organization
called pachama not pachamama pachama
which
they pay monthly to reforestation
efforts to ensure that they have a net
positive carbon footprint so visit
mudwater.com
uh
visit mudwater.com darkhorse to support
the show and use darkhorse at checkout
for five dollars off that's
mud water not spelled as you were
expecting it m-u-d-w-t-r
dot com slash darkhorse use darkhorse at
checkout for five dollars off
all right next up public goods dyslexia
be gone
public goods can be your new one-stop
shop for high quality everyday
essentials their ingredients are
carefully sourced and affordable public
goods has glassware and sponges and hand
soap coconut oil black tea vinegar and
spices garlic almonds and for after your
garlic almonds breath mints too
they've got niche items like bone broth
concentrate and gluten-free pasta and
plantain ships
public goods cares about health and
sustainability for its customers and for
the planet they plant one tree
for every order placed and the
ingredients are ethically sourced
their products are largely free of
harmful ingredients and additives public
goods products have great design too the
aesthetic is simple and clean and does
not shout late stage capitalism every
time you look on the counter which is
nice it is nice
finally their subscription service is
efficient and simple and easy to use
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials in one place it
really is an everything store for dark
horse listeners we have the following
offer receive 15 off your first public
goods order with no minimum purchase
they are so confident that you will
absolutely love their products and come
back again and again that they are
giving you 15 to spend on your first
purchase
go to publicgoods.com
darkhorse
use the code darkhorse at checkout
that's public goods p u b l i c g o o d
s dot com forward slash dark horse to
receive 15 off your first order
excellent
and i was going to say that today's
episode is brought to you by the number
93 in the letter p
and read the index from the hunter
gatherer's guide
the 21st century for the letter p but
it seems familiar to me and although my
notes do not suggest that we've done p
before i'm going to skip it for this
week and perhaps bring you
next week's episode with the letter p
and just make sure that i haven't in
fact used p before right i don't think
you have but i i can't be so i'd know
halfway through the index but then it
would be awkward to
yeah you know i i have a spreadsheet and
all but i think i think i fell down the
job a little bit so i'm not sure enough
okay so um
we're gonna talk about school today uh
we originally had not just a chapter on
childhood which we talked about last
week and a chapter on school in this
book but we actually had two school
chapters we had a chapter on school and
a chapter on higher ed
and the idea
in part of this book is that every
single one of these chapters including i
mean really every single one of the
sections in every one of these chapters
could easily be expanded into a book of
its own
um and so we took even more out of the
school chapter than we did out of many
other parts of the book um
so i would like us to use this as a way
to open up the conversation about school
there's lots to say um but you know
understand that this is this will not be
the last time that we're talking about
school and uh and this conversation
right now will not necessarily be about
um
the particular things going on right now
in school so there's plenty there's
plenty to discuss there
you would suggested maybe
maybe beginning with some
some personal stories about what our
experiences in school were yeah i think
this is actually essential for our
listeners and viewers to understand
where we're coming from and there's
something interesting not only in the
fact that you and i
had very different experiences in school
but that um our relationship brought
those two sets of experiences together
and you know
i
came to understand what your perspective
was and you came to understand what my
perspective was and i think this worked
out really well for our students because
effectively
each of us had the vicarious experience
of the other and therefore there was a
larger range of students that made
intuitive sense to us at the point we we
ended up in front of the classroom
before you spell it out i guess i would
say i would add to that um
i think it's easy for uh good students
people who just have an easy time in
school to imagine that those who don't
are
are either not capable or they're
slacking and they're lazy and it's easy
i think for people who
are not doing well in school
but know that they have capacity
to imagine of the good students that
they are
brown noses and uninteresting and
uncreative
and that while there are i'm sure people
in those categories uh in each case
there are slackers and there are brown
noses and there are uncreative people
who do well in school and for sure and
there are uh lazy people who don't um
but the uh
that's that is hardly the complete
solution set no it's hardly the complete
solution set and in fact um i i
obviously you and i uh you and i know
that we are both exceptional for the
categories that we would have been
slotted into
and that begins to tell you something
about what school is and what it might
be if we did it right
so let me just say from from my
perspective
failed for me in the second grade i
remember it happening and of course i
have an adult's viewpoint
retrospectively looking back on that
period but i remember
that effectively i was in a
public school the
teacher had too many students and my
inability to do the work that was being
presented just simply created a
predicament which is does the teacher
invest very heavily in figuring out
what's going on with that student very
probably fail and thereby neglect the
rest of the students who are in a
position to do the work
or does the teacher effectively throw up
their hands and say well let me teach
the people who are uh in a position to
you know to follow the directions that
they're given so
why did it fail for me it failed because
of something that very frequently gets
described as dyslexia and i must say i'm
not really a believer in the category
and it's not that i find anything
troubling about the idea of being
defective in some way i have defects i'm
colorblind in a way that clearly blocks
my ability to see color normally it
doesn't bother me that i am
i find it interesting i wouldn't change
it if i could press a button and not be
colorblind anymore but the dyslexia
thing never rang true because
it doesn't make sense that dyslexia
would be a
um
a male adaptation and the reason is that
writing and reading are so new that what
does it even mean to say that you're
defective with respect to your ability
to do these things that have only been
around for less than 8 000 years and for
which most people had no experience
until you know the last several hundred
years so
if it is true that there is some
inability for some of us to do these
things you know um i might also not be
good at grand theft auto right are we
gonna create a
disorder and say oh he's grand theft
auto defective or is the idea hey maybe
grand theft auto is an essential part of
being human
um
so in any case i i imagine that there's
a bell curve distribution of how awesome
your
mind is at the point that somebody
points it towards reading how awesome
your mind is at
picking up symbols off the page and
transducing them into meaning and i'm at
the low end of that which makes me
dyslexic but i also know that everybody
gets what i've got when they're tired or
when their glasses are dirty
right it's not like we see the world in
some different way it's like reading
itself as a challenge and i also know
that the reason that reading is a
challenge is because
paper and ink were expensive until 20
minutes ago right and so
because paper and ink are expensive
there's pressure to make the font as
small as possible to get as much text
onto as few pages as possible with a
little ink and so okay we've picked a
font size that renders some fraction of
us not great at processing the symbols
and if you
jack up the font size it gets a lot
easier so again this is all suggesting
some sort of technological novelty got
in the road for schooling but
nonetheless it did something for me
which was i think
totally essential to becoming
who i am
right it broke the link between school
and me school gave up on me i gave up on
it at the time i thought that was the
end of my intellectual life which hurt
because my family was an intellectual
family
and i assumed well i guess i'll have to
do something else
right and then it turned out that wasn't
the case because
i had
smart people around me i had a
grandfather who took kids
very very seriously and he mentored
me even though he didn't see any you
know reason to give up on me and so all
of that worked out pretty well and what
it meant was that i was sort of in
school because that's what one did but
it wasn't an effective place nor was it
where i got my validation and it left me
well in a funny spot
i was on
russell brand's program uh i think it's
just out today and he and i had a good
long conversation about what i call the
cosmic joke
and the cosmic joke is something you can
tell a thousand different ways and some
of the ways that the cosmic joke gets
told you're the butt of that joke and
the idea that i really detest school and
i have since very very early on and yet
didn't manage to escape it until you and
i were more or less unceremoniously
hurled out of our professorships uh in
2017. you know i had been in school from
the point i was five years old to
your late 40s right to my late 40s so
that's a hell of a thing to happen to
you if you really dislike school
on the other hand
i did get because evergreen was such a
strange place i did get the opportunity
to reinvent school in a way that it
would have worked for me and it worked
for a lot of people who weren't good at
school which was an incredibly fun
rewarding uh
fascinating experience and so that's
more or less it school didn't work
something else did
you know i i think i only got through
school because every fifth or sixth
teacher saw something in me and was
willing to bend or break rules for me
right had those people not been there at
the right moment i probably just would
have gone the other way and who knows
what i would have ended up doing but
having gotten to the front of the
classroom at a college where there were
no rules about what you had to teach
were couldn't teach or how to teach you
could completely reinvent the
the classroom which i did and it was
great and so anyway okay that's my side
of the
the equation
let's talk about your side and then
we'll talk about how they fit together
um
um
oh boy we we could just go on forever on
this couldn't we um
so i had school was easy for me i read
early i i was driven to read and i loved
reading and so the part of
the part of your story and the other
people who were diagnosed or not with
dyslexia uh who who i've come to know
well
um that i cannot i i don't have any
match for in my experience is
um where you you avoid reading you find
it actually painful in some in some
regards um it's true that uh there are
moments you know fatigue and such
where
um
reading may become a little bit more
difficult but it's i don't think it ever
you know what you said about
um everyone has this experience of sort
of
seeing the world seeing the written word
um as if as as if through a so-called
dyslexic size i'm not sure that's true
um because things can get um more
confusing but they're still deeply
enjoyable i mean you know that i find
i love to explore and i almost never
want to go out without without some
written word with me in case just in
case you know i will spend you know
hours on end just watching animals do
what they do but i also want
to to have something to read just in
case and
um and there are many people like you
who are not who are not driven to have
the written word with them
uh and i think that's
that the fact that the written word is
what modern schooling revolves around is
uh is the biggest challenge for many
people uh that
that is true
um i also
had um you know parents who
were good at school and who but who were
willing when i brought things home that
didn't make sense to say
yeah that's not the way to do it and so
specifically i remembering my dad
um i was i was not just you know very
much a reader and a writer but very
mathy and my dad had actually taught
math at the graduate level
before he became a computer scientist
and he thought the way that math was
being taught in the 70s in elementary
school in the 80s in middle and high
school
was insane
and he basically said you know don't
don't do it that way why are you
memorizing things we will do this from
first principles as much as possible
and it was fun and exciting and
wonderful and
and it
it ensured
that my love of math was maintained as
opposed to disappeared by the
by the compulsory schooling that we were
all being put through
uh it is also true i am certain and
there is uh ample research to back this
up
that modern compulsory schooling at
least in the you know sort of standard
public and most private school
modes in the weird
world
are more designed for girl typical ways
of learning than for boy typical ways of
learning
and
that while it is not i think good for
girls either to be expected to sit in
rows
neatly tidily quietly and raise their
hands whenever they have anything to say
and
have to be excused to do anything
physical with their bodies
girls are girls are typically
even you know non-gender typical girls
like i was you know a fairly tomboyish
girl girls are more able to sort of put
up with that level of
frankly authoritarian you know top-down
um description of what it is that you
need to do in order to be allowed to
learn than boys are
so um i don't know there's
there's a ton more to talk about but you
know i just i was rewarded by school
early
uh for reasons i think that came from uh
within my family and within me i did not
take those rewards as the source of my
value which is i think you know it's
that conflation that allows school to to
beat people that if
if school can convince you that when it
says you're good
that means you're good and therefore you
should keep chasing it's its description
of you being good and when school tells
you you're bad that means you are bad
and school is right and you need to
chase school's
um association of badness or goodness
then then school has won and then your
motivational structure has been hacked
by a system that is probably not
interested in your well-being but
actually interested in uh in containing
you yeah at best it's being efficient at
some massive expense to you and at worst
it's actually
uh grooving you for a role that is in
the interest of the system more than it
is in your interest and i so
if we can
talk about what it was like uh you know
to fall in love with each other and
um encounter this very
different kind of creature you know i of
course had been dealing with great
students my whole life
and um
you know some of them are your friends
right right sure and some of them are
total pains in the asses
[Music]
one of my best buddies in high school
was uh you know
valedictorian you know top of the class
so i it's not like i didn't get along
with people uh who were good at school
but i did find that there was something
about most such people
um where there was a way in which
there was a kind of
ability to think that was clearly
that waned over time right and this was
not the case with you or with john or
with the other
um you know excellent students who i did
end up hanging out with
but it was definitely the exception
rather than the rule because
you know what i saw and then what i
think we saw uh when we were teaching
was
that school is a very gameable system
and that a lot of what
great student syndrome is is it's people
who have gotten lured into
the game of school and they've gotten
very good at getting school to spit out
the
um the hallmarks of success and
the chances are if you get very good at
the school game and you see well if i'm
succeeding at school that i am good at
this and i am knowledgeable that
effectively what you you don't realize
what you're giving up which is the
ability to see
where it's wrong for example and if
there's one thing that is essential to
making progress in the world it is
figuring out where the world has stuff
wrong right so in some sense the
most important thing is easily lost if
you're too good at school unless you
have you know in your case um a father
who uh
how have you said it he um
did not suffer fools gladly
yeah
right and so the point was somebody you
know it's
the ideal thing is more or less what you
had which was the ability to do school
but not an obligation to listen to it
when it was wrong and
that's the hard thing it's what we
should be shooting for in the in the
creation of school structures but it's
very hard you either create something
that isn't very effective at all or it's
too effective and it causes a loss of
the ability to see what doesn't add up
yeah no absolutely uh maybe that's maybe
i think i think we should continue this
conversation but let's try let's read
this first excerpt because i think i
think it fits nicely with what we're
talking about so this
again from chapter 10 of a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
what is school
for children school can be understood as
love and parenting commodified
put another way part of what school is
is parenting that has been outsourced
we have already seen many of the harms
and risks of reductionism yet one more
is that reductionism facilitates the
commodification of easily quantifiable
things while tending to ignore those
things that are less quantifiable
thus school becomes about metrics how
much how fast how well did the little
one read do their multiplication tables
memorize a poem
it should go without saying that there
is clear and enduring value in reading
multiplication and poetry
a focus on speed and quantity is an
error however with me what myriad things
are not being learned in school because
they succumb less easily to reductionist
assessments
school is based on an economic
efficiency while being unimaginative
about what could be accomplished the
economics not to mention the perverse
incentives behind compulsory schooling
of school tend to fill children's heads
with knowledge without showing them a
path to wisdom
perhaps school should serve the purpose
of helping young people grapple with the
question who am i and what am i going to
do about it that incidentally that the
footnote there is to derek jensen's
excellent book on education
another way of phrasing this might be
what's the biggest and most important
problem i can solve with my gifts and
skills or how do i find my consciousness
my truest self
done well then school can provide a
great platform for formalizing and
delivering rights of passage
rather than focusing on any version of
these questions though modern schooling
especially the compulsory sort
widespread across the weird world is
more apt to teach quiescence and
conformity
what if we took as one of the goals of
school teaching children how to
understand and hack their own incentive
structures
knock them off the low adaptive peaks
that they are surely on i'm not good at
math languages or sports or conversely
i'm so good at math languages sports
that other things fail to grab my
attention
what if we knock them off the slow
adaptive peaks into valleys that are
uncomfortable
but from where there are many possible
peaks to climb
or perhaps school should reveal to
children that fringe positions should be
explored and considered not thrown out
immediately on the basis that they are
unpopular
betting against the fringe is an easy
bet usually a safe one and when done in
a tone of paternalistic indulgence say
or authoritarian disdain it usually
shuts down descent
while most fringe ideas are in fact
wrong it is exactly from the fringe that
progress is made
this is where the paradigm shifts happen
this is where innovation and creativity
occur and yes most of it is wrong or
useless but the most important ideas on
which we now base our understanding of
the world and our society came from the
fringe
the sun is the center of the solar
system species adapt their environments
over time
humans can create technology that allows
us to communicate across time and space
to fly to create and explore virtual
worlds these were all impossible ideas
laughable at the time
those who quickly join in laughing at
all fringe ideas now
would have been laughing at all of those
ideas in their time
school should be fun
but it should not be gameable a child
shouldn't be able to win at school
although many do and many more lose on
it
social rules and mores are learned at
school but at its base school should be
about discovering truth both universal
and local
school is for better and for worse is
stand in for parents for kin group for
those with whom the child has shared
fate
schools should not therefore teach
through fear
risk and challenge help children learn
as with parenting this requires early
tight bonding during which a secure base
is established which provides children
the confidence to go out adventuring
fairly early because they know that
someone has their back no matter what
school that operates by fear will teach
the opposite lesson
fear is an easy mechanism of control and
so it should not be surprising that
teachers use fear to control students of
all ages
as corporal punishment in the classroom
fell out of favor in many but not all
places psychological and emotional
control replaced it
it leaves fewer marks
children are threatened with poor grades
poor test scores and having their
parents inform that they have behaved
badly which most children will hear as
you're a bad person
the rise of metrics within a system
which are often overly simple
wrong-headed and only
pseudo-quantitative tends to accompany a
decay in social trust how can good
teachers stuck in a system of escalating
metrics imposed from the outside
counteract the prevailing cultural
forces
one approach which will be more
effective with older children and young
adults is for teachers to explicitly
hand away their own authority by telling
students not to trust them just because
they are the figure in the front of the
room
when a teacher then does earn the
respect and the trust of her students
such that she becomes a legitimate
authority figure one with authority that
was earned rather than assumed her
authority will better serve both the
students and their education
using fear to keep children seated in
neat and tidy rows to keep their eyes
forward and their mouths closed to keep
them from moving their bodies at all but
for a few scheduled moments in each day
this will help create adults who are
unable to regulate their own bodies and
senses
unable to trust in their own ability to
make decisions and likely to demand
similarly controlled environments in
their adult lives trigger warnings safe
spaces and the like
for young school children one solution
would be having a garden at school and
spending time in it in all sorts of
weather
frequent field trips to natural areas
and spending time actually outside
rather than in the climate-controlled
protection of the nature center will
help too
will it always be comfortable
no
will some children be ill-prepared for
rain or wind or sun
yes
will they learn from small early
mistakes to start taking responsibility
for their own bodies and fates and so
get better at navigating the world yes
yes they will
humans are anti-fragile exposure to
discomfort and uncertainty physical
emotional intellectual is necessary
preparing students to understand risk it
encourages them to expand their world
views and embrace experiences that lead
to maturity this does however come at a
cost
sorry i lost it understanding risk
cannot completely protect individuals
from danger
in short risk is risky tragedies will
happen and that's no minor thing for
those of us who have been lucky to avoid
it it's nearly impossible to imagine how
a person continues on if their child has
died or if they have been involved in
someone else's child dying
tragedies that happen because someone
introduced risk into a school trip are
easy to point to the story is often easy
to tell and compelling to hear
by contrast population level tragedies
those that happen because whole swathes
of the population have difficulty
navigating risk and so avoided at all
costs this is also a tragedy and much
further reaching
modern school tends to protect against
individual tragedies while facilitating
the larger societal ones
arrange all little boys and girls neatly
in rows assign them seats and tell them
never to speak unless they are called on
first because that will make it easier
to keep track of them
at the same time at home teach the
little boys and girls that they are each
the center of the entire universe and
that they may and in fact should
interrupt adults at any moment for any
reason
teach the children that temper tantrums
are acceptable by caving to them
whenever they erupt and also tell the
children that they are the most precious
and infallible beings in existence and
as such any criticism is a crime against
their core selves
we should not be surprised when children
raised this way can make no sense of the
confused and confusing messages coming
at them from home and from school
nor should it surprise us when they
gravitate to the systems that are most
gameable
mom doesn't like it when i scream rewind
but if i persist at it she gives in as a
way to make me stop
noted
teacher leaves me alone if i
occasionally contribute a comment in
class and earn good grades even though
i'm learning nothing by regurgitating
from a textbook
got it
congratulations society you've
successfully produced self-satisfied
whiners who are accustomed to getting
what they want who are good at school
but not at thinking and who are in fact
neither smart nor wise
so something i have said let's we'll do
another short excerpt soon but something
i have said about um having taught at
evergreen for 15 years is that it made
me less of a misanthrope
that i had
little hope for most of humanity having
gone through you know having been an
excellent student um and a student who
also loved school not someone who was
just regurgitating but i really loved
school and i learned from school and i
had a series of just extraordinary
teachers
but by and large i felt that uh
non-human animals were much more
enjoyable to spend time with and to
learn from and
um in part because so much of so much
conversation seemed to me to be about
small talk and regurgitating truisms
that weren't actually true or that if
you dug a little bit you couldn't you
just didn't get very far with people
and then
to my surprise as much as anyone's i
ended up taking this job then we both
were at which was an academic job that
focused so much on teaching and so much
less on research that this is really
where we put a lot of our creative and
analytical
focus for for some number of years is
figuring out how to be excellent
educators and communicators and people
who were engaging through the whole the
whole human
and
hell if i didn't come to love humanity a
lot more because those the evergreen
students were not the elites right they
were you know there were there was
certainly in every classroom students
who had been excellent students
you know people who had been excellent
students people who came from you know
from from some privilege in terms of the
the you know upper middle class or even
upper class resource base they had come
from but
more students always or were students
who were eligible for pell grants
students who were first in their
families to go to college
non-traditional age veterans
students who had been homeschooled and
unschooled and you know gone to sudbury
in montessori and waldorf and all of
these alternatives and you know just
throw them all in together in a
classroom where now we can do whatever
we we want to actually educate and
almost every single one of my students
in every single one of the programs that
i taught taught me something and
surprised me and
um were
you know demonstrating
what a beautiful thing a human can be
yeah it was
very much a different experience than
one would have had let's say you had the
job at harvard right hey if you had the
job at harvard you probably it wasn't
your primary focus you were probably
there for some other reason sure um
and then the other thing is if you got
the best student in every high school
who has shown up at harvard it's a very
different class than a group of people
who
[Music]
are
extremely
quirky and unusual and each one you know
it's not that they've all gotten good at
the same game
to the extent that they've gotten there
they've learned very different things
along the way
and you know i can even hear in this
description what somebody at one of
those high-powered places is thinking
about the sort of pitiful classrooms
full of people that we had but that was
exactly not what they were the amount of
potential in those rooms was amazing
yeah and the
job of figuring out how to unleash it
was like nothing else that's right i i
used to
spend all summer
thinking about what i was going to say
on the first day of class
right in order to set it in motion the
right way and i don't think i ever once
said what i intended to say right it
always was some
speech i didn't see coming
but you know
one of the things that we both did in
different ways is what is alluded to in
that excerpt i just read from which is
to say
um
you know i'm up here with the degree and
i'll be writing your evaluation at the
end with enough grades and that was
actually a good thing but um you know i
don't i don't work for you
you know you're not my employees and i'm
not your boss
um and i'm not your employee and you're
not my boss uh but also
the fact that i'm standing here sort of
sage on the stage style um does not mean
that you should trust me yet
uh you know you should show me respect
as i should show you respect as he as a
fellow human being um but i have to earn
uh your trust such that you know
hopefully you know day after day week
after week month after month
you come to find that you don't need to
be skeptical of anything that i say that
sounds outside of your domain because
you've come to recognize that i am
actually trustworthy but don't assume
i'm trustworthy just because someone
hired me because i got a degree because
there are plenty of people who've been
hired who have degrees who are in no way
trustworthy and don't know anything
worth worth teaching right and
um i
for my part came to look for the one or
better a few students that were present
no matter what you did if you put
together an interesting program
description
it would attract at least one and often
several students who were willing to
push back sometimes they didn't even
realize it because they've never been
invited to exactly you're talking about
from moment one because over time lots
of students would would well that's my
point is if you've got the one at least
one right if let's say let's say it's
the worst case right and you you know
this only happened a couple times in 14
years of teaching but um let's say
you've only got one person bold enough
to contradict the professor on day one
right and so then okay you've got to
find them how are you going to do that
well
you know i used to this is gonna sound
terrible i know it's gonna sound
terrible but it's amazing uh
it's amazing that you don't destroy the
respect in the room if you do things
with a certain glint in your eye and
that sort of thing but
um
to the extent that nobody is ready to do
that because they don't know that you're
really serious and that you do actually
want them to push back
you have to say things that are
sufficiently outlandish as if you mean
them
so that somebody cannot stand it any
longer and has to challenge you right
and
um
that you know
to the extent that you have students
that already know you know if they're
repeat students you know or if they've
been your students and i'd come in and
guest lectured and they knew that this
was the game then they'd be ready to go
right away but if they didn't know you
have to say something that causes them
to say god damn it that can't be right
and even if it's going to cost me my
my evaluation in this class i i'm gonna
challenge right
and then the person does it
and they get rewarded for doing it right
because of course there's some place
that you can go from whatever it is that
you've uh you've gotten them into and it
becomes clear that it's fun right and
then others want in on that game too and
so the question is really how do you
create the lesson that says this isn't
like another classroom where you're
going to be punished for revealing what
i don't know this is a classroom room
where you actually you will have
succeeded at the point you get to the
thing that i can't answer the question
and then we'll talk about how it might
in principle be answered right please
let us all reveal the holes in each
other's understanding right yeah and so
you know one of the things that uh
was somewhere in a lot of those first
day speeches was there's no such thing
as a biologist right why is there no
such thing as a biologist because
biology some of the things you said i
still wonder what the hell you meant by
them well this one's perfectly clear
right um to the extent that biology is a
dozen different fields
and that we're talking about
you know an incredible diversity of
organisms and that we don't understand
even how the simplest cell functions
completely there's lots of things we can
say about things that go on in that cell
but we can't explain how the cell works
right
so the point is you cannot it's not like
um
you know it's not like analytical
chemistry where you can effectively
master a landscape of you know
analytical chemistry up to a point it's
a landscape so big that the point is
what you can have are the tools that
allow you to unpack the landscape and
then at the point that some set of
questions becomes interesting to you you
can pursue them
um
yeah i mean
i guess i guess i i used to have
occasionally um
you know if i was doing vertebrate
evolution for instance uh and i'd end up
uh awarding credit in
vertebrate zoology and phylogenetic
systematics and
uh and evolutionary and and and you know
both evolutionary theory and depending
on what they've done maybe you know
research methods
and then i'd have students come at the
end and say well okay but you know do i
do i get credit in biology
like it's it's it's all biology right um
but and you know the same thing when i
was doing animal behavior i'd give you
know
credit and behavioral ecology and in
tropical by you know tropical zoology
depending on you know and what it was
and in uh statistics and you know
various things that we were teaching
okay but you know what about the biology
um so i i guess i feel i feel like
you're contributing to the confusion
well
contributing to the confusion is how you
teach but um no
i'm not denying that there is a field
that deserves to be called biology my
point is it is impossible to be expert
across it and you know how many times
did we encounter people who thought they
were expert in
some taxon or some process who didn't
know thing one about the way adaptive
evolution works yeah right and the point
is well okay that's not my specialty and
it's like well yes but your the
questions you don't understand that
there's an edge to the questions that
you're good at answering that you know
is right at the place where we start
getting to the question about why it
looks the way it does so so part of what
you're
i think i think the point i just don't i
don't love this particular approach and
you know this is this is something that
we revealed when we talked together too
that you know we you know we in some
ways share a brain and yet we have very
different approaches both because of our
own experiences in school and our own
developmental experiences and just our
you know our our proclivities and
interests
um but
part of what you're saying
revealing is uh the more of a generalist
you are the more that you can use
uh first principles and rules of thumb
and analytical toolkit
to approach any problem as opposed to
i've got this stuff memorized and oh
i've got this let me see is it on my is
it on my cheat sheet is it on my recipe
list like how do i deal with this thing
the more of a generalist you are the
better able you're going to be for
certainly this modern world that we're
in
and um you know that is a match too
for i think why well
you know modern k-12 schooling is
failing for a number of reasons part of
it is all of the injunctions being
placed on teachers and um you know just
like you have
teachers have so many fewer degrees of
freedom uh within which to move that the
best teachers um can't reveal that they
that they are you know really really
skillful um but in also so that's sort
of coming from the the government end of
things um
schools of ed which are you know
captured by a bunch of crazy ideology
but even before that they're training
people very very narrowly and so you
know you have people going like well you
know i teach i teach history it's like
you know the younger the kids are and
really we found this at
the college level but certainly the
younger the kids are
the more you want someone in the front
of that room and you're going to have to
be you know rewarding their efforts more
than
elementary school teachers are currently
rewarded but the more you want someone
in front of that room who's capable of
taking any question that comes at them
well right and you know you know
why are the plants growing now why you
know
like any number of questions that little
kids ask
that some you know that that a teacher
will say well that you know that's not
in the curriculum today ricky like
any teacher who says that to a kid is is
helping kill off the curiosity and
creativity and helping turn
helping turn that child into a cog which
you know is it's in the book too but i
literally had a
colleague
a faculty member say at one point well
they're going to end up cogs anyway so
of course i'm going to help turn them
into cods yeah okay look those people
are terrible my point was
it's tools you can look up the facts
it's tools right and so what's tools the
reason that there's no such thing as a
biologist because if we imagine a
biologist is somebody who knows biology
it's impossible to know biology what you
can know is how these things tend to
work and then you can go look at the
piece that is necessary for a particular
set of puzzles
and
you know so that you know of course i
deliberately said it in a way that
causes the brain to you know throw an
error and the reason i did that was
because i wanted them to think carefully
about what their expectation oh you've
got a biologist teaching this class what
does that mean does that mean that
they're in you know an expert in all
things biology because i find that
extremely unlikely right
it's hard enough to get a faculty of
biologists that you know could be expert
in all sorts of things what you're going
to get
is you know deep dives here and there
and if you're lucky you're going to get
a
you know a high capacity to wield the
logical tools that will allow you to
unpack the various puzzles that might be
might be relevant right
um and just this this reminds me of so
this is john taylor gatto who's who
recently died but he was i think he won
awards for his teaching in the new york
city schools and he's written a number
of books weapons of mass instruction is
another one this one is dumbing us down
the hidden curriculum of compulsory
schooling both highly recommended but
here's just a little
section from the preface of dumbing us
down
um he's talking about um the 30 years oh
he says over the past 30 years i've used
my classes as a laboratory where i could
learn a broader range of what human
possibility is the whole catalog of
hopes and fears and also as a place
where i could study what releases and
what inhibits human power
during that time i've come i john taylor
gato have come to believe that genius is
an exceedingly common human quality
probably natural to most of us
he says he didn't want to accept that
notion um he went to two elite
universities that taught him quite the
opposite
um but he says the trouble was that the
unlikeliest kids kept demonstrating to
me a random moment so many of the
hallmarks of human excellence insight
wisdom justice resourcefulness courage
originality that i became confused
and then he says was it possible i had
been hired not to enlarge children's
power but to diminish it
that seemed crazy on the face of it but
slowly i began to realize that the bells
and the confinement the crazy sequences
the age segregation the lack of privacy
the constant surveillance and all the
rest of the national curriculum of
schooling were designed exactly as if
someone had set out to prevent children
from learning how to think and act to
coax them into addiction and dependent
behavior
bit by bit i began to devise guerrilla
exercises to allow as many of the kids i
taught as possible the raw material
people have always used to educate
themselves
privacy
choice
freedom from surveillance and as broader
range of situations and human
associations as my limited power and
resources could manage
so
some of the
incoherence and the fracturing and the
just
constant barragement of
untrue things masquerading as true
things
in not just school but the media
today
especially in the last year and a half
but also maybe especially in the last
five years and 10 years and you know it
goes on and on
um follows from
the lack of privacy the constant
surveillance the segregation by you know
what developmental stage you're at uh
that we are inculcating our schools yeah
and um i think the tricky part and you
know i don't always know
with gato i mean i think he nails the
phenomenon perfectly right he
diagnoses exactly the catastrophe that
school is and then i
figured out it was because you know
because it gave me the freedom to do so
by cutting me loose
the question is why is it like that
right and you know i think the problem
is that there are a lot of pieces to
that puzzle
there definitely is an influence of
employers that want
compliant
employees they don't want them too
clever because employees that are too
clever are a problem but it's not as
good walks through the deep history of
compulsory schooling coming out of
germany and then the us at the turn of
the last century with you know the era
of the rubber barons and such
um you know right taylorism but what i'm
saying is
it there are components of this
there are also ways that those
components actually work right it's you
know what are the confusions of a person
who finds themselves at the head of a
corporation and doesn't necessarily know
what they want is employees that have
been
cognitively hobbled so they're not too
independent-minded right that person
doesn't sound like that inside their own
mind right they have a list of things
that they want that are desirable things
and they don't either
understand or allow themselves to
understand the tensions between those
things and other desirable things that
they might want right so you know we see
for example so i mean part you're
pointing out that there there are
cognitive dissonances that are required
that because most people aren't super
villains or superheroes right you don't
it's easy to imagine the the nasty ceo
who sounds like that but that's not
actually what most of them sound like
and
making stark the cognitive dissonances
in our own heads is part of what uh
being an educated person is i think
right it is the ability to decamp and
take up a position that you don't hold
and see how robust it is if you you know
give it a good solid go yeah um you know
and there are also ways of
compartmentalizing right so some great
corporations have had a skunk works in
which the rules look very different than
they do right in other words
even the entity that wants compliant
employees to do the job also knows that
it has to have unruly people somewhere
in order to innovate the next job right
um and so
i i don't know why school looks the way
that it does i know it's
built to fail where it's built to fail
if what you think its purpose is is to
create enhanced capacity minds and i
completely agree with godo
i mean it's almost a tautology from my
perspective that we are all born with
genius level capacity and it gets
quickly narrow you know all of us who
are born intact right that the human
mind it's not like some of us are
programmed to be super capable and
others are programmed not to be right
you've you know
back to what we talked about last week
we're talking about the blankest slate
you know in all of you know animalia why
is it the blanket slate because that
offers the possibility of innovating new
programs that are capable of extracting
more from the world than a
pre-programmed creature could so there
seems to be
an assumption among the uh the
chattering class the so-called
intelligentsia uh that most people can't
handle the truth right you know
basically
and that therefore it needs to be dumbed
down it needs to be uh obscured in order
to deliver the message to get people to
do what we've all agreed behind the
scenes uh we need to do
and i think you're in my experience
um
in
in 14 15 years of classrooms plus the
many years that we spent um being
teaching assistants in graduate school
revealed
quite the opposite actually that you
know every
almost everyone is capable of taking in
diverse
weird you know crappy data that has
conflicting signal in it and that
requires nuance to parse
and
um trying to make sense of it and
that does not guarantee that everyone
will come to the same conclusion of
course but then neither does democracy
and you know we it's a weird moment to
be in
when um the people in the world's
democracies are simultaneously arguing
that we need to
obscure information from people in order
to
um to mandate compliance with
conclusions yeah it's like the generic
built-in cover story for which there is
no evidence right actually
you know yes if you shout fire people
may stampede toward the door but does
that mean you know at the point you
start obscuring that there's a fire
you're the villain right the question is
you know can we deal with the question
of how to get the truth into the public
sphere and you know some people will be
hearing this and you know clutching
their pearls over you know did they miss
the game theory problem if i tell them
the truth they won't do the right thing
those things are real yep on the other
hand we have a tremendous amount of
evidence that not only are humans
capable of addressing those things but
that they do it beautifully um up until
modernity right it's modernity that
undoes well so i mean there's is it is
it modernity and you know it being
modernity is and hyper novelty to use
our term is really one of the prime
theses of our book
but
as part of modernity is it also
possibly
a problem of scale such that those
things that have worked in the past so
it's not so the thesis in the book is
largely um it's not you know we are we
are best suited to change you know the
human niche is niche switching uh and we
we deal with change so so well and so
fast but the rate of change has become
something that even we cannot keep up
with so that is you know that's one of
the main theses of the book but
can we do so
even if the rate of change were to slow
a little bit with these numbers
well with the numbers that we have
unfortunately
there's obviously a question right
there's obviously you know i don't know
that dunbar's number is actually a
number but there is a limit above which
you can't keep track of the uh details
of some number of individuals lives and
that creates problems so there are scale
dependent issues to be sure the point is
we also have systems in which we can say
look
this is a problem we can't deal with
above this scale that's why we need a
system that does the job right and
these things evolve naturally right you
know catholicism doesn't make any sense
uh if you try to understand it at the
level of kin selection which is part of
why uh evolutionary biologists don't
deal well with questions of
large religious
beliefs and structures the point is
evolution was dealing with this problem
now we have new problems that are
modular systems that do
work well at unprecedented scales create
right so for example
if you
if you
are a fisherman
and your
being a fisherman is something that you
picked up from your parent and you will
pass to your children it's the family
job your interest in the fishery being
healthy is built in you intuit it and as
the fishery begins to fail it causes you
to worry as it should whereas
if you are part of a corporation that is
extracting fish from the sea but it is
also extracting lumber from the land and
it is you know doing 17 other things and
what's more the members of the board of
uh the corporation are also members of
the boards of other corporations and so
the point is well this is all like you
know skin cells that can be sluffed and
as long as we have some new thing to do
it doesn't matter that we destroyed our
last opportunity and if we didn't
somebody else would have so we might as
well the point is you've just created a
tragedy of the commons where
individuals who had a coherent way of
being that continued from one generation
to the next would have avoided it right
for
tragedy of the aggregate
it's a tragedy of the new mechanism by
which the commons will supposedly be
managed but it couldn't possibly be
right so it's like we you know you will
hear people uh
challenge the idea of the tragedy of the
commons
based on the fact that eleanor ostrom
proved it wasn't true but they don't
really understand that both things are
true the tragedy of the commons is real
eleanor ostrom's discovery of the
mechanisms whereby people avoid
tragedies of the commons are real and
then this novel thing treasure the
commons isn't your inherent fate but it
could be it is simultaneously
inescapable and easily solved and that's
the problem right it's inescapable if
you structure things a certain way and
it's easily solved if you structure them
a different way and the question is well
which have you done
are you know are you magically hoping
that it's going to solve itself because
it won't or do you have a coherent
structure that
exists because it succeeded in
preventing tragedies of the comments
from unfolding um so anyway it none of
this is all that hard right you just
have to know what to focus on and you
can't have oh no it's it's a bit hard
and it requires keeping a number of
things in in your head at the same time
and i do think um that again you know
it's
it's it's become all too easy for me and
frankly it became very easy for me in
grad school and just got worse for the
you know many years that we were
professors
to point my fingers squarely at the
people who are supposedly our peers and
say this is actually on you
like this is not on the many people who
you claim to be caring about and
educating because i hear what you sound
like when you leave the room and how you
talk about the students now you talk
about the people who don't go to college
and you know frankly it's unacceptable
and
um and your degrees often don't mean
anything because i've also seen what
those programs look like where you got
the degrees and they're often worthless
and they're not teaching you how to
think and they're not teaching you how
to hold you know things in your head
that seem like they couldn't possibly be
true and sit with that for long enough
go like okay
instead of just getting so uncomfortable
so quickly that you kind of just make a
hasty decision and throw one away and
it's possible that one you threw away
was the true one and that this was the
one in error or that it's actually
different contexts and you can't you
need to know that these are both
possible but in different contexts
there is there is a refusal to sit with
uncertainty
that is um i think
all too often a result of a modern um
education and the more educated you are
the more likely you are to be really
uncomfortable with that uncertainty
uh i think it's even worse because not
only are these programs very often the
academic programs yeah degree process
something like worthless but that they
are actually successful at doing
something that is antithetical to their
stated purpose right so what they
effectively do is take highly capable
people
and
cause them to become responsible to
certain kinds of dog whistles that snap
them in line and you know at first uh
it's an issue where
yes you may
be able to think across a
a domain very effectively and then some
thing
can't quite stomach the last step in
that domain and so it
backs you off just slightly but
eventually once you've once you've
allowed something to stand between uh an
individual and the pursuit of the
complete truth as best we can understand
it
what the point is you've just you know
you just
basically
breached the dam
right once you have that ability to uh
you know hold back on the truth a little
bit the point is it just becomes
captured and it sells false stories that
are actually about economic well-being
or political power
and the problem is you've got all of
these people
with fancy degrees who yes if they had
been raised in a different system might
be very very good in their domain but in
fact are capable of telling flat out
lies
because something
you know successfully signals to them
hey you know you go too far down that
road and you're going to starve
right there are no they're not enough
jobs and you won't have one right if you
keep going that direction right and this
you know this
this is a conversation for another time
probably but you know this is what
tenure is supposed to um to grant right
like tenure is supposed to give provide
the protection against such perverse
incentives
that uh now you can tell all the truth
right but uh certainly for scientists it
can't possibly be fully protective
because as we've talked about in in
previous
episodes at the moment the way that
science is funded means that your tenure
doesn't get you anything like that
tenure doesn't get you nih grants or nsf
grants you need to be asking the right
kinds of questions and have peers that
are going to read your grant application
uh with uh with a kind eye and then you
know peer reviewers uh for the
publication of it and so it you know it
it it has become you know as
as such systems will
it has become a series of sort of nested
sets of uh
of cronies
and
somehow when you say that uh you get
told that you're not speaking truth even
though it's exactly the truth well
we've got another problem with respect
to tenure which is that the things that
you are absolutely required to be good
at in order to get it are the things
that guarantee that once you have it
you're not going to use it for anything
interesting right and so said the guy
who had tenure to another person who had
tenure
at evergreen
it wasn't even called tenure so the
point is evergreen was so weird and the
whole process was so bizarre that yes we
did have the thing that was closest to
tenure at evergreen look how much good
it did us but um right but nonetheless
you know it is exactly the same puzzle
as uh well how do you how do you get to
be president
right right you have to demonstrate that
you are you know
good at
greasing the wheels and taking orders
from the people who've got the power and
then once you have that job the point is
what you're excellent at is corruption
right which is exactly why um frankly
unity 2020 was
whatever you may think of the plan
itself the right idea which is you have
to speed somebody past the corruption
and get them into the office that has
the power in order that when they get
into that office they will do something
that isn't corrupt right um so
yep yeah
um
how about this here's a quote from um
the great robert persig in zen in the
art of motorcycle maintenance and
inquiry into values which is a book i
highly recommend
the real purpose of the scientific
method
is to make sure nature hasn't misled you
into thinking you know something you
actually don't know
if you get careless or go romanticizing
scientific information giving it a
flourish here and there nature will soon
make a complete fool out of you
so this you know this in service not of
talking about all of school i don't know
that has particular relevance in uh
discussion of literature or art perhaps
but um
you know when
zen was written in what 1974 i think i
didn't have i don't have it written down
um something 70s i believe and here he
says uh you know if you get careless
or go romanticizing scientific
information giving it a flourish here or
there that sounds like hashtag follow
the science yeah to me right this is
this is exactly you know he's he's
seeing it a long time ago and there are
others there you know there are
certainly other important uh scientific
papers from that era and the 60s as well
saying ah you know wait a minute we you
know i see some
some fields beginning to go off the
rails and being less analytical less
creative more
you know canalized
and
even that discussion is becoming harder
and harder to have
now
well
the problem
is what we were talking about earlier
where there's a sort of sense that
certain things are
true in a way that we can actually
skip the methodological part and because
they're true and it's really important
that people get them then you know the
point is it's time for you know
honorable pr on behalf of these true
things and
uh i 100 agree and you know we have said
many times different versions of the
single value of the scientific method is
that it tells you where what you think
is uh correct isn't right the whole
point of the thing is to force you into
the place where you can see what is true
in spite of what you expected if it was
all intuitive and we could all just say
well we know x y and z you wouldn't need
this method
and so what we are now living in is an
era
in which
people think that the landscape of those
things that you can just intuit this
thing is good and that thing is bad and
here's the solution to our problem right
and the point is well that stuff it's
not like we've got you know everybody
here went to college we don't need to
run through all of those things to
figure out whether they're right let's
just get the message to the masses and
the answer is
do you understand what you're i mean
especially in complex systems right if
you're talking about these supposedly
obvious truths about what we should be
doing and shouldn't be doing
in a complex system or you know even
worse as uh the case is with cobit where
you have a three-layered complex system
right
um
no you need to think very carefully
about whether or not something in that
set of layers reverses one of the signs
on something and makes the conclusion
something completely counter-intuitive
i'm just it's not clear to me what the
three layers are you're talking about
um you've got uh
the
immune system a complex system in and of
itself
embedded in a creature a complex system
embedded in a society with a
pandemic right that's three complex
systems layered on top of each other and
the idea of well we all know what the
solutions to these things are
and let's deploy it as quick as possible
it's like you do not know what game you
are playing you do not know how
um
how intricate the interrelationships are
in each of those layers and then
how little we know about the
relationships between the layers
and so anyway we get sold a bill of
goods but the basic point is look
if you want science done right
you have to insulate it completely from
those forces that think they know the
truth and are just trying to get it out
there right yeah you know because what
that ends up being is just an invitation
to
market forces it's an invitation to
corruption to the
co-op thing of the scientific voice
right and that's really what it is it's
a voice an authoritative voice that
isn't about science that is being used
to get people to think in a particular
way um for what reason maybe we don't
even know yet but um but it's a very
dangerous process and the point is what
the only antidote is real science and
real science is quirky and weird and
done by people with you know who may not
be the easiest to get along with they
may not be your favorite person at the
cocktail party but you know you need
people who are good at the method and
know how to deploy it and know that they
can't back down just because it tells
them something counterintuitive yeah and
it doesn't it it often doesn't look like
you're expecting you know the it's it's
not linear and it doesn't necessarily
come in a lab coat with glassware
right
right the trappings of science are not
science science is a method right and
then you know as we've demonstrated
before you know science can be done in a
laboratory it can also be done wearing
rubber boots and
you know wielding a machete right
science is a method that works anywhere
where there are processes to be
understood
exactly um
okay a little little pivot here a little
bit more sure short excerpts
one and a half page excerpt
from again the school chapter of a
higher um a hunter-gatherer's guide to
the 21st century
this section is called the world is not
about you
from the school chapter
children have been harmed through
through gnome oh boy
the world did i mention that the cat
drank my water
here i have some i would yes i would
love some of your water because um you
did not put your paw in this no no not
even once
thank you much better
the world is not about you
children have been harmed through no
fault of their own by a perfect storm of
societal factors that emerged in the
late 20th and early 21st century which
we have already reviewed
the rise of pharmaceuticals being
prescribed to children helicopter and
snow plow parenting and the near
ubiquity of screens never mind what is
on them have all made school an even
more difficult place than it once was
in the united states add to these the
economic and political forces that have
reduced school funding while increasing
testing thus cutting the creativity and
freedom of teachers off at the knees
when heather that's me
primed her students for study abroad
trips to panama or ecuador in advance of
embarking with them she was trying to
build not just the academic skills
required for the work but also the
social and psychological ones required
for extended trips outside of anything
most of them had previously experienced
she would ask them what is your
relationship with risk and what is your
relationship with comfort
just because you can say in advance that
you will be okay with the bugs and the
mud than not having access to the
internet doesn't mean that you actually
will be
perhaps most important of all though we
are going to leave ourselves open to
serendipity we cannot know what all will
happen on this trip we're going to go
and some interesting things will happen
those conversations included discussions
of how risk is different in landscapes
that haven't been rendered safe by
liability lawsuits and in which medical
help is far far away
we talked about the hidden hazards of
the jungle rising water tree falls
compared with the familiar ones like
snakes and big cats that people are
primed to be scared of
risk and potential go hand in hand
we need to let children including
college students risk getting hurt
protection from pain guarantees weakness
fragility and greater suffering in the
future
the discomfort may be physical emotional
or intellectual my ankle my feelings my
worldview and all need to be experienced
to learn and grow
the students whom we took on study
abroad trips were carefully chosen
mature capable smart and adept
even so the inability to control our
surroundings the intentionality of
succumbing to serendipity when in the
jungle threw many of them into states of
confusion which sometimes manifested as
anger
many of them believed themselves to be
excited about exploration about
discovery but only when it looked and
felt as they'd already imagined
by inculcating in children the sense
that order is always better than chaos
and that being easily counted and
prioritizing doing things that are
easily counted is the honorable way to
go through school and therefore life
many would extrapolate society creates
adults who bristle at the unexpected and
the new
not only doesn't the jungle look or feel
as you are allowed to believe from even
the best nature documentaries but the
people on the streets of panama city or
quito aren't what you think the cloud
forest and the people who called it home
long before the inca or the spaniards
ever arrived will surprise you too as
will everything else if you take your
blinders off and let yourself experience
the world without taking everything so
personally
mostly the world is not about you but
you can learn from it and an education
should allow you to do just that
yeah this is uh
you know it's funny it seems so obvious
that the world is not about you and yet
the nature of
one's interaction on the internet i
think especially if it's you know if
you're young enough that it is your
developmental experience
reifies the false belief that it is
about you
and
it's um
it's
epistemologically
devastating
right
the ability to understand yourself as a
biased observer and to try to minimize
that is
somewhat dependent on your ability to
understand that your
your centrality to your own perception
is a bad thing and not a good thing yeah
no that and then that's that's right and
that's actually a great segue to i
wanted to talk about a little bit about
um
embodiment as well embodied cognition
and embodied perception and
you know the idea that um
many people have largely i think without
having
formalized that this is what they
believe in their heads
that you can learn sufficiently just by
being passive by taking it in
and
you know this is one of the
less frequently objections to video
games as a whole as a holistic learning
environment and as we said i think last
week you know neither of us feel that
video games are inherently you know a
negative
but that the higher the proportion of
your uh your life they take up the more
likely you are to be limited in how you
can how you can understand yourself in
the world and so there's this there's
this classic
pretty immoral i think i think it
couldn't be done today uh research on
learning and kittens from 1963 called
movement produced stimulation and the
development of visually guided behavior
and it's different from actually from
the one that we are more familiar with
in which
pairs of kittens from ten litters
are
kept in darkness for all but three hours
a day and then for three hours one of
them is basically harnessed up and
allowed to move and walk and explore and
then the other one is basically on the
other end of like a carousel
um from the one who's harnessed up but
passive and so everything that the one
that the one sees the other sees as well
but the one is actively engaging with
the world in order to interact with it
and uh the second kitten in each case is
um is only passively experiencing it and
those kittens who only passive
experience passively experience but see
everything that the actively engaged
kittens do
are rendered basically helpless and
hopeless they they can't they cannot
make sense of their world later on uh
and
there you know there's there's plenty of
work that has followed from that there's
a whole you know field called embodied
cognition that recognizes actually that
when we are restricted restricted from
moving our own bodies in relation to the
world we find
we find ourselves incapable and often
don't recognize that we are incapable
so i think i think for me that may be
the most important piece that we also
lack the recognition of our own and
capability
uh i found
um
some you know
an interesting
piece by a woman named speakerman from
2018 called carousel kittens the case
for a value-based internet of things
uh in which she says human beings are
highly complex biological systems with
an embodied consciousness that develops
intelligence through experience of the
world
technology is making that experience
passive rather than active and so this
is bigger than school this is this is
about you know what what the world is
that we are creating for ourselves but i
would say that school too this model of
school where you sit still and you know
there's a moment to be active and it's
called recess and maybe we'll even skip
recess if we feel like we need to cram
more stuff in to study for the test
is is effectively a way of
assuring us that our children would grow
up incapable of being fully functioning
adults
uh i i have tried to encapsulate this in
the distinction between
knowing how something is done and
knowing how to do it which sounds like
they are synonyms but they are not right
in other words you you can know a lot
about um
how you know you could you could be a an
avid fan of pole vaulting
and never having never have pole vaulted
and the point is you'd be thoroughly
inept at the point you attempted it
because
you know yes you could know a lot about
what makes a good pole vaulter better
than a bad one but the point is
the knowing isn't in the part of you
that is involved in the doing and
the most important thing and i know that
the reason
that you're you're
making this point central here is
that at some level
those who have only received the
information don't know which part of it
is likely to be false that's right right
you can read a textbook full of stuff
discerning right they don't know what
the truth sounds like and how it sounds
different than
uh fictions that are plausible but not
right
um and it is essential the the ability
to you know discernment is really about
that distinction between the things that
are actually true and the things that
only sound true right that's the
important
border and
you know we have an educational system
that is obsessed with you know
delivering things in this abstract form
that does not allow you to detect the
distinction
and um
yeah it's a it's a it's an absolute
tragedy i think in some sense
uh you know
you're hitting the nail on the head that
the the passive kitten is a thoroughly
disabled kitten no matter what they've
seen
yes right yes you can have been shown
the world but if you didn't
take yourself around that world and make
decisions uh about how you would engage
it um
you you are just a passive vessel and
your passivity early will
turn you into someone who can only be
passive later you lose your agency you
lose the potential to be an active and
engaged individual in the world and
that's that's what so much of this
embodied cognition research is
is demonstrating which really like like
like with a lot of evolutionary biology
it feels obvious in retrospect and it's
like you know of course of course you
can't separate
humans um you
there there is no
simple duality right there is no split
between mind and body and you can just
you know treat the you know make sure
that your body is functioning and then
focus entirely on your mind they are
engaging one another there are feedback
systems and it will not work neither
will work fully if you treat them as
separate systems
all right are you ready for a curveball
please all right this raises an issue um
hey zach can you show the uh
the
picture that we managed to extract from
from the camera
uh the bee
oh
so god so you took this beautiful
picture which for people just listening
what what are we looking at you're
looking at a single very large flower
this is from the san juans on the coast
like literally uh maybe 100 meters from
the water
and
very
promontory yeah on a rocky windblown
bluff and you're looking at something
like a sunflower
and a bee is approaching
to pollinate now the reason i raise this
is
there was something in the quote you
read about technology making this
passive engagement with the world
um
normal
and i'm
you know there's this paradox for me i
love photography i love to take images
especially
of
creatures
i've almost you know i've used them in
my teaching because i had them right
they weren't necessary because there are
lots of images in the world
and it's kind of an antiquated form like
why do you want a still image in the
first place right a video can capture so
much more
but i know that for myself there's
something about the puzzle involved you
know they're really two puzzles if
you're interested in photographing
animals one is do you understand the
animal well enough
that you can do something other than
just be lucky right because luck is not
there's not enough of it to get good
photographs at a high rate you have to
understand the creatures which sometimes
means i don't know anything about that
creature but i'm going to watch it for
several days and try to get photos of it
and figure out enough about what it's
going to do that i can position myself
so that i'm in the right place right
um you know so in this case with the b
you know i have a zillion photographs of
bees on flowers right they're pretty
boring
right catching the b on the way in and
managing to get the b in focus right
required you know
this you were there for a while
i was there for a while and you know
it's a problem i've never quite solved
previously so this was a case in which i
you know a half an hour or 45 minute
investment finally solved a puzzle i
hadn't solved before and you know it's a
highly technological puzzle too right
you've got to wield the camera just
right and
you know in order to get the both the
flower and the bee in focus you have to
be yeah they have to be in a plane and
anyway so my point is in this case it's
actually technology
that sort of sets a bar it creates a
useful puzzle to solve yeah and the
change in the technology does things too
the way i shoot photographs now is you
know has almost very little to do with
what it was like back in the film era
right because your constraints are
different and
um
anyway
only my only point is
that figuring out how to solve puzzles
in the physical world whether or not
they're technological puzzles is a way
of training your mind to see
things whether it's how the animal
behaves so that i can be in a position
to photograph it when it shows up or
something like that so anyway i would
just advocate
take any real realm even if your
interface with it is technological and
figure out how to
is puzzlize a word no
how to puzzle it um so that uh there's
there are solvable difficult but
solvable problems and that they're
interesting enough problems to you that
you that your motivational structure
will cause you to do it there it is
um
let's just
maybe begin to wrap it up with two items
from
the corrective lens this week from the
school chapter first one
i'm on the wrong page you are yeah all
right i'm going to fill in here i'm
getting that okay just the next page
um
here we go okay higher education in
particular should recognize that
civilization needs citizens capable of
openness and inquiry these should
therefore be the hallmarks of higher ed
the need for nimble thinking creativity
in both the posing of questions in the
search for their solutions an ability to
return to first principles rather than
rely on mnemonics and received wisdom
these are ever more important as we move
forward in the 21st century
a misunderstanding of how work will look
in the future is driving people to
specialize earlier and more narrowly
higher ed is the natural place to
counteract that trend and push toward
greater breadth nuance integration
students of traditional college age
today cannot accurately predict what
their career will look like by the time
they are 70
50 or even 30.
colleges where breadth should be
inculcated
and
so again higher education in particular
should recognize that
authority is not to be used as a
bludgeon to shut down the exchange of
ideas
bob trivers evolutionary biologist park
salons and our mentor in college
once advised us to seek positions in
which we taught undergraduates
his reasoning was this
undergrads do not yet know the field and
so are likely to ask questions that you
aren't expecting
dumb questions if you will are ones
imagined to already be settled
when the educator is confronted with
such questions one of three things is
likely to be true
one sometimes the field is right and the
answer is simple full stop
two sometimes the field is right but the
answer is complex nuanced or subtle
figuring out or remembering how to
explain that complexity or subtlety is
worth the time of any thinker who
deserves the title
and three sometimes the field is wrong
and the answer is not understood but it
takes a naive view of the matter to ask
the question
yeah it's so true you lose the ability
to see the question
and
when you're immersed in it and you know
any anyone who's taught at all you know
it doesn't require being sort of you
know a
deep a researcher into something very
deep anyone who's taught can see
themselves moving farther and farther
from the minds of their students the
longer they do it you know the i you
know how was it to be naive now even
like an open wonderful sense not in a
you know an ignorant sense but like what
was that and how can i maintain my
theory of mind and understand what it's
like to be in the heads of these people
in front of me so that i can best
reach them and communicate with them and
they can reach me and communicate with
me
right and the you know the
uh ungrooved mind asks
questions
aplenty that aren't so useful but in
it's it's very much of the question of
the fringe right the fringe is mostly
wrong but within that sea of wrongness
there are the hints of the next frontier
and the
the ungrooved mind
doesn't know which of their questions
are the good ones necessarily but the
point is you're ungrouped i've never
heard this this
well if you become you know
if you become expert in
let's take the this example
our colleagues
do not understand that the waiting time
problem in evolutionary biology is
actually real because it was delivered
in a sea of not very good critiques that
came from intelligent design folks but
the point is it's actually a good
question is there enough time for the
process that you know to have explained
the adaptations that you see and claim
have been
produced by it right and if the answer
is no
it doesn't necessarily imply what the
people who ask the question think it
implies it implies maybe you're looking
for another layer of process
right and so anyway the point is the
grooved minds are so used to saying
here's the process that explains it so
by group so i'm just i'm hung up on this
grooved versus ungroup that sounds like
it could
for me as someone who's done comparative
anatomy i'm thinking like you know the
the more the more actual grooves and
brains the higher the cognitive capacity
i don't think that's what you're meaning
to imply i don't know i mean grooved as
in catalyzed like yes
which the point is if you're very
excellent at something it has a lot to
do with following those grooves because
they lead to useful places rather than
to spinning your wheels so you want it
so okay i know i need to get to this
point that's eight steps down and i'm
not gonna every time spend time making
the first five decisions because i just
already know where i have to go and the
decision tree is right which is what
trivers was telling us was that you need
somebody who is naive in order to help
you see where you've actually made a
cognitive choice that you don't realize
is a choice because you make it every
time right
similarly i would just add that
the
there's a parallel experience to the one
i described at first where somebody in
the class is willing to push back
because they just can't stand to hear
you say something that isn't right and
then once they do it and it turns out
that
they get praised for it rather than get
scolded other people want in on the game
and suddenly you've got a whole class
full of people pushing back on you and
each other and it's very vibrant there's
this other thing the flip side is
so it requires
a teacher a professor who
knows that what they think they know
might not be true
and is willing to say in front of the
class oh
uh yeah that's probably right actually i
had that wrong or
i don't think so and then come back the
next day the next week whatever it is
and say yep you know you were right i
was wrong right or you can do it
intentionally and so the point is you
can drop something in
right you can do you can do it
intentionally but you you would not no
one would do that if they weren't
comfortable doing what i just said
because because and yeah we've known too
many of these people who are like well i
can't go there because then they're
going to start pushing back over on what
is my domain and i can't take pushback
in my domain yeah we know and that's
that's unfortunately a big part of the
problem and it's not that there aren't
plenty of people who are capable
out there but if they fear being
revealed as incapable of some part of
what they claim essential to their to
their you know their depth um that that
will basically you know the entire thing
will turn out to have been a potemkin
university or something yes they they
rigged their whole teaching lives around
not being exposed for their own uh
limits and you know yes that's a
terrible teacher an insecure teacher is
is a hazard to to your ability to think
um but anyway the thing i wanted to
point out was there's the encouraging
the student to push back because all of
the rewards come from them actually
spotting things that don't yet add up
and figuring out what's in those gaps
and all of that
and then there's the the detection that
a student is being socially motivated
which is bad right now most teachers use
social
motivation to get students to accomplish
stuff even good teachers right
but the problem is there's a limit to
that to the extent that somebody is very
plugged into what the social authority
is telling them to do it depends on it
being a good authority otherwise it's
just a mechanism to
be manipulated into nonsense and so
the other thing i would do which you saw
me do many times was when i detected
that somebody
was trying to tell me what they thought
i wanted to hear in order to get a pat
on the head right i would
lead them down a logical chain right to
some place that was dead wrong and then
i would basically cut off the limb
behind them so that they would get the
experience of like oh
yeah trying to tell this person what
they want to hear is actually not the
road somewhere it's actually the road to
not knowing where you are and being a
little bit embarrassed and um and but
then you know you've got this great
lesson which is okay if i just led you
six steps down something to something we
all know is false
and you agreed with every step along the
way
where was your error it's crazy to me
how much you enjoy this
well that's the thing is i mean you know
you will agree
i was not hated by my students so it
wasn't like they it wasn't like no it
didn't it didn't work for absolutely
everyone but it was pretty clear right
away those those relatively few people
for whom this wouldn't work and um no
not quite quite the opposite um and
that's not um
what i just said has nothing to do with
um
anything on there and just that um
some
you know i did i did a lot of things
that you never did and you did a number
of things in the classroom that i never
did and
some of those things that you did i
would watch and go i
i see that that is effective and that no
one else is doing it and i just could
not
bear
to do what he is doing i i couldn't all
right so here's one for you
um couple of weeks ago i got a
communication from a former student
somebody who had actually given me a lot
of trouble right and was not when when
you when you were in professional
relationship with one another yeah when
you were this is somebody this is
somebody who did not quite get what the
style of teaching was about it was the
rare exceptional person highly
intelligent
but
didn't dig it and said so and anyway i
mean that was actually that could that
happened sometimes it was interesting
yeah yeah anyway she contacted me and
she said by the way
first of all she asked if i remembered
who she was of course i remember who she
was you were totally we were thorns in
each other's sides right exactly um
but uh i'm not gonna use her name
because i didn't check it with her but
um anyway if you're out there you know
who you are you have an unusual name and
uh she said you know i just wanted to
tell you that i don't think i was ready
for those lessons but um i now get what
you were up to and uh i really
appreciate what you were doing so anyway
even in the cases where it didn't
necessarily work i think there's um
there's the ability to
to see what it's its point is and i mean
this too this this is one of the things
that um
that i i don't actually see a way around
this but that modern education
is limited in that the assessment
happens too soon
right um that the assessment both by
faculty of students and by students of
faculty
happens when you're still just in the
thick of it and you know maybe you know
maybe your professor managed to game it
such that your last week was an
incredible amount of fun and you feel
like you learned a lot and so you're
going to write this glowing evaluation
and maybe they weren't thinking about it
and so their evaluations are more
variable even though they actually you
know a year on five years 10 years 20
years on you realize oh that's the
person i learned from why did i write
that sort of mediocre evaluation of them
oh because they didn't you know game it
so that my i was feeling full of
dopamine at the point that i wrote the
thing and the same same thing for
faculty writing
evaluations of students
um and
you know i used to say actually
especially after the study abroad
programs you know okay you know final
final thing is not a science thing but
um i just want you know a short essay on
some aspect of this
be it you know five and a half eight
week 11 week whatever it was
um expedition through either panama or
ecuador um that you
that you were surprised by and that you
can analyze in some depth
and i would invite people to
write me another one in a year and two
years in three years so you know i'm not
i won't
i won't be in this relationship with you
then you are under no obligation and um
i'm of course under no obligation to
read it but i'm telling you i will
anyone who sends me these a year on two
years on three years on reflection about
this thing that we just did that i
created on your behalf and on my behalf
and on our behalf and that i allowed a
lot of serendipity to happen so that i
couldn't predict everything that would
happen or all the lessons learned i
would love to see those um and there are
a couple there are a couple of people um
who do send me um who send me those you
know years many years later and
it's amazing because you know the idea
of assessment when you're still in the
thick of the thing that you're supposed
to have learned
imagines again that learning that you
know that
that the short time horizon is where
it's at and it's not
well there are three things
there one it reflects what you said up
top about
i'm not your employee you're not mine
yeah they're a superficial resemblances
between this relationship and that but
that's not what this is and to the
extent that anybody
would take seriously your assignment
that gets turned in at their discretion
years after
any relationship any formal relationship
at all exists the point is well actually
you as the professor were trying to
create an experience that was meaningful
enough that years later it would still
be on your mind and that's of course
what you should be doing right
and the fact that uh
you know
you and i know if you've been in the
field with students right you've been
suffering with them you've been you know
shocked
alongside them right you've seen amazing
things together
right you know it's obviously
the experience is
one off for each of us but there's so
much that gets that's in that
relationship that doesn't get quantified
it doesn't get evaluated and of course
it builds this connection that years
later they want to tell you you know
what that actually meant to me you know
what it meant to me i didn't get it for
three years right right and then finally
it dawned on me and of course the idea
that you're important enough to them
that they would think to tell you
right is a demonstration that this this
actually did live up to what
the experience was supposed to be it
wasn't encapsulated in any way and
that's what you know the the all too
common and pat phrase now you know
lifelong learners right but that's
there's honor in that that's what we all
should seek to be
and uh an educational system that is
functional
uh should inculcate that desire in
people who are currently called students
and may later be called teachers or
carpenters or scientists or whatever it
is they're they're called
and they should want to both continue to
learn and
yes it's deeply human to want to share
with those who helped create the
experiences in which they learned the
thing
what it is they learned
yeah and uh yeah unfortunately the
attempt to systematize education has
driven all of this stuff that's hard to
explain and even harder to defend you
know it's driven and out of the system
for most people so they just don't
ever encounter it i guess it's terribly
sad
indeed
all right are we there i think so
all right we will we will no doubt be
talking about school again but uh that's
it for now um hopefully there are some
questions in the q a that we will come
to shortly about school so we can
continue the conversation a bit we're
going to take a break we aim for it to
be 15 minutes there's some technical
problems that are not on our end that
kept it way too long last time we'll be
back as soon as we can be
with our q a go to
darkhorsesubmissions.com
to
to pose questions we never get to all of
them we get to as many as we can
uh consider joining one or both of our
patreons again um the window for asking
questions on mine for next week's
private q a is open right now
you can get uh stuff at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org you can ask
logistical questions at
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
and please consider liking this video
sharing this video subscribing to
all four of the relevant channels both
on youtube here brett weinstein and
darkhorse podcast clips and on odyssey
same things
you have anything to say
go solve some puzzles solve some puzzles
be good to the ones you love get out no
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
you